let's say that we have the function f of
X is equal to x squared plus 1 and what
we want to do is we want to figure out
the average value of our function our
function f on the interval on the closed
interval between 0 and let's say between
0 and 3 and I encourage you to pause
this video and especially if you've seen
the other videos on introducing the idea
of the average value of a function
figure out what this is what is the
average value of our function f over
this interval so I'm assuming you've had
a go at it let's just visualize what's
going on and then we can we can actually
find the average so that's my y-axis
this is my x-axis now over the interval
between 0 and 3 so let's say that this
is 0 this is 1 2 3 it's a closed
interval when when x is 0 f of 0 is
going to be 1 so we're going to be we're
going to be right over here F of 1 is 2
so it's going to be so it's 1 2 3
actually let me make my scale a little
bit smaller on that have to go all the
way up to not up to 10 so this is going
to be 10 this is going to be 5 and then
1 2 3
actually let me the hardest part is
making this even so let's see this is
going to be in the middle pretty good
and then C in the middle and then we
have that not good enough all right so
we're going to be we're going to be
there we're going to be there I have
obviously different scales for x and
y-axes 2 squared plus 1 is 5 3 squared
plus 1 is 10 3 squared plus 1 is 10 so
it's going to look something like this
this is what our function is going to
look like so that's the graph of y is
equal to f of X and we care about the
average value on the interval closed
interval between 0 and 3 between the 0
and
three so one way to think about you can
apply the formula but it's very
important to think about what does that
formula actually mean and once again you
shouldn't memorize this formula because
it actually kind of falls out of what it
actually means so the average of our
function is going to be it's going to be
equal to the definite integral over this
interval so essentially the area under
this curve so it's going to be the
definite integral from 0 to 3 of f of X
which is x squared plus 1 DX and we're
going to take this area we're going to
take this area right over here and we're
going to divide it by the width of our
interval to essentially come up with the
average height or the average value of
our function so we're going to divide it
by B minus a or 3-0 which is just going
to be 3 and so now we just have to
evaluate this so this is going to be
equal to 1/3 times C the antiderivative
of x squared is X to the third over 3
antiderivative of 1 is X and we're going
to evaluate it from 0 to 3 and so this
is going to be equal to 1/3 times when
we evaluate it at 3 let me use another
color here when we evaluated at 3 it's
going to be 3 to the third divided by 3
well that's just going to be 27 divided
by 3 that's 9 plus 3 and then when we
evaluate at 0 minus 0 minus 0 so it's
just minus minus when you evaluate at 0
it's just going to be 0 and so we are
left with I want to make the brackets
that same color this is going to be 1/3
times 12 1/3 times 12 which is equal to
4 which is equal to 4 so this is the
average value of our function the
average value of our function over this
interval over this interval is equal the
average value of our function is equal
to 4 and notice our function actually
hits that value at some point in the
interval at some point in the interval
something lower
then two but greater than one we could
maybe call that see it looks like our
function hits that value and this is
actually this comes this is it this is
actually a generally true thing this is
a mean value theorem for integrals that
and we'll go into more depth there but
you can see that this kind of does look
like it's average value that if you
imagine the box if you multiply this
height this average value times this
with you would have this area right over
here and this area right over here is
the same this area that I'm highlighting
in yellow right over here is the same as
the area under the curve because we have
the average height times the width is
the same thing as the area under the
curve so anyway hopefully you found that
interesting